I didn't know that one out of every two
fish was farmed instead of caught our
culture has been is just repeating the
patterns of the wild which is feeding
small fish to big fish you know they go
out and catch 20 million tons a year of
herring and anchovy and menhaden these
little bony oily fish they grind them up
and press them out into a fat ingredient
called fish oil and a protein ingredient
called fish meal and those are
commodities that are internationally
traded and those are the key ingredients
to make alcohol to feed so that's how
you get these special proteins and oils
that these marine creatures require to
be healthy fish meal has the price band
of fish Mill has more than doubled and
it's gone up between five and six acts
since 1995 we like dirty co2 because
that's cheap or people might pay us to
take it and in our bacteria you could
say eat or remediate a lot of the things
that the EPA is actually concerned about
these bacteria that can take the co2 and
use the hydrogen and grow the proteins
in those bacteria are intentionally very
similar to the proteins of the small
fish that the big fish eat in the wild
puts off about 1.2 million tons a year
of co2 we could make 600,000 tons a year
of our nuovo meal from that
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are still at Indy bio demo
day we are talking to David say now from
novo nutrients what's up hey thanks for
coming on the show yes yes absolutely
and also congratulations on finishing up
the pitch and getting the company
rolling so let's talk about this so and
as we talk about making neutral food
from co2 yeah as we talk about that I
want to also give us the quick bit on
that and then we'll get into the detail
but I also want to know about who you
are and how you even got to this point
so you know give us a quick bit and
start with the how you got to the point
we're at okay
so I graduated college at the dawn of
the commercial Internet and I developed
a taste for entrepreneurship in that
context all right and then in the early
2000s I realized that I didn't want to
keep making ecommerce sites for baseball
cap collectors and that kind of thing I
wanted to do something that was more
important for fundamental human needs
and so not long after that I discovered
aquaculture which is to say I really had
no idea where seafood was coming from
before that I didn't know that one out
of every two fish was farmed instead of
caught even at that time that's the step
and now it's more now it's majority of
seafood is farmed and but there was this
incredible pioneering work being done by
people in the open ocean like using the
other 98% of the Earth's water surface
that we don't do much with to grow food
and like Jacques Cousteau said we must
farm the oceans as we farmed the land
and he was like way ahead of his time
but that's starting to happen now and
it's an incredible resource so I got X I
got fired up by reading on article in
Wired magazine and then I found that one
of my one of my college classmates a
friend of a friend had independently
developed an identical interest and he's
a was a very successful
Sharyl entrepreneur and so essentially
he had the
I had the time and we started a group
called aqua copia together originally as
the aquaculture investor on earth his
family office and later as an
independent fund manager company with a
venture fund and so how did you go from
aqua topia to novo nutrients aqua copia
like cornucopia yeah yeah so basically
how it was always clear to me that one
of the biggest opportunities in
aquaculture was what you feed the fish
because everything else is very specific
a salmon farm is very different from a
tilapia farm which is quite different
from an oyster farm or a seaweed farm
the one thing that like not all but many
of those things have in common and
almost aqua doesn't comment is you got
to feed the thing so you can eat it and
everything in the ocean has evolved for
hundreds of millions of years to eat
other things in the ocean yeah right but
on land for the last 20,000 years we've
gotten good at at producing a few things
oil seeds and grains mostly and there's
not much of an overlap between those
right fish and shrimp in the ocean they
want to eat other fish and other shrimp
that's not what we can grow in our
fields and so there's this fundamental
technology opportunity actually a
biotech opportunities things to serve
that grow
ocean food to feed ocean food that we
want to eat absolutely or hazard least
simulate it be nutritionally equivalent
to it yeah okay so now yeah so do you
continue so really you know what our
culture has been is just repeating the
patterns of the wild which is feeding
small fish to big fish and so you know
they go out and catch 20 million tons a
year of herring and anchovy and menhaden
these little bony oily fish they grind
them up and press them out into a fat
ingredient called fish oil and a protein
ingredient called fish meal and those
are commodities that are internationally
traded and those are the key ingredients
to make alcohol to your feed so that's
how you get these special proteins and
oils that these marine creatures require
to be healthy but those are commodities
that have been under tremendous pressure
and the prices keep going up and up so
like even in the time that I've
in the business since 2004 fishmeal has
the price banda fishmeal has more than
doubled and it's gone up between five
and six acts since 1995 well and that's
the wrong way we want it to drop yeah I
think so if we want to preserve our
oceans and not overfish them and if we
if we want good food to be relatively
inexpensive if you're gonna eat an
animal you need to control the cost of
what you're feeding that animal and you
want to do it with something that he's
also doesn't have contaminants because
you know that mercury and things like
that will end up in people and so there
are a lot of reasons to try to make use
of inexpensive resources to generate
feed and I met this company novo
nutrients before it wasn't over
nutrients when they were more of us a
little more of a science project and
realized that they were taking untreated
industrial missions of co2 basically
pollution and turning it into nutrition
and that blew my mind yeah yeah what how
does that work what is the nutrients so
it's a lot like the way that that those
plants in the field work right if you're
if you're a stalk of wheat it's using
photosynthesis to take co2 from the air
and solar energy and then you know
that's what grows the cells in the plant
forms the wheat that eventually you know
is inbred there's some water and soil
yeah exactly that and so we need exactly
the same things we we also use water we
also but not nearly as much a tiny tiny
tiny fraction of the water that you
would use to grow a plant on land and we
need a little we need a little bit of
nitrogen and phosphorus and sulfur like
the elements that you want but the
biggest thing that we need is co2 and
then secondarily we need hydrogen so in
our case it's the same kind of co2
capture that plants do we're just doing
in an industrial setting where the co2
is being made anyway by a cement plant
or by the meal milling paper making
steel these are all things that produce
a tremendous amount of co2 that has
nowhere to go
besides the sky and so we give it a
in life in a very valuable way so the
co2 that is a byproduct of steel and
these massive industrial processes can
then have a nova nutrients yeah section
of the basically you just got it you get
the co2 to us and we feed it to our
bacteria okay and now let's okay cool so
let's talk about this so the co2 comes
to you
what does novo nutrients have that we
said feed it to the back yeah okay and
then they keep telling us about okay
yeah so this is actually the core of our
intellectual property and the heart of
our technology you can tell us yeah yeah
which is to say it's a framework for
designing consortium sourcing consortium
means different kinds of microbes that
work together where the whole is greater
than the sum of the parts and so in our
consortium the core primary producers
are these bacteria that can take the co2
and use the hydrogen and grow but then
there's another layer around them of
secondary producers other species other
strains that can't survive directly on
co2 and hydrogen but the waste products
of the prime producers give them what
they need to thrive and so in this way
like consortium nature which are you
almost never find a microbe by itself
because in the same way that nature
abhors a vacuum
evolution is going to use all the
resources that are available in an area
and basically you know organisms are
going to evolve and move in until almost
all the resources are used and at the
microbial level it's it because these
consortium and so that's our our patent
application or one of them at least is
around a very particular subset of all
the possible consortium that is
specifically designed to to be able to
produce nutrition very efficiently
quickly and inexpensively from
industrial co2 so what
exactly happens the bacteria is a
bacteria that takes the co2 and uses
that to do what that enables it to grow
and exactly so these are microbes that
grow by cell division yes
so it's exponential growth and we're
just giving them the food that they need
to split to make more bacteria and then
that those microbes are the food that
the aquaculture wants yeah I mean it's
fish meal exactly the the proteins in
those bacteria are intentionally very
similar to the proteins of the small
fish that the big fish eat in the wild
so the profile of a protein is like what
amino acids are in it which of the
building blocks of protein are in and to
what degrees and so our inventor and
founder Brian Sefton designed this
consortium
specifically to try to get an amino acid
profile that's like an anchovy which is
sort of the gold standard for marine
proteins and so we've gotten it's very
interesting to see the graphs next to
each other we've gotten quite quite
close but what's even more interesting
is if you take away the fish meal amino
acid graph and put in the nutritional
needs of a specific animal like a salmon
or a shrimp because that's really what
you wanted you don't want to necessarily
substitute for what they eat you want to
subdue for what they should be eating
what would be the perfect protein for
them and there's this concept of of an
ideal protein which is actually that and
we're doing some work to try to achieve
ideal proteins but there'll be next
generation for us that's not what we
have today yeah interesting so then
there's this you kind of you put it as a
golden standard yeah Marit time it's
called marine approach it's called up
the the good stuff is called super prime
fish meal super prime fish meal
interesting so then the same composition
of amino acids that make up the proteins
and fish meal you have bacteria that
yeah we're hoping from soon we're close
close better in some worse than others
but we're working on this is really a
first draft or us what we have today and
we have many ways to improve as we go to
mark to mark three and so forth and then
David how receptive are the fish in the
aquaculture to eating the fish meal so
we we just did a test actually so the
USDA and the US Fish and Wildlife
Service have a joint lab in Bozeman
Montana where this is pretty much all
they do yeah our tax dollars at work
but in this case you know to create
better and cheaper seafood is really is
mainly what they're thinking about and
so they set aside 200 trout half of them
got the controlled diet which had the
super prime fish meal in it and half of
them got a diet which was I think it was
about 40 percent Nova meal which is much
higher than you would actually use in a
real situation but they wanted to see is
it safe that's the first thing yeah and
yeah the safety levels were like almost
identical but then it it also you could
also measure growth and what we saw was
especially as time went on and the fish
were bigger and therefore you know it'll
be more expensive to feed them because
they eat more when they're bigger our
growth rates were better than the
control and so that's like very
promising for us yeah so yeah growth
rates is huge and then also I'm curious
if the the cost of feed becomes much
less as well yeah so you're not going in
taking a crap loads of fish from the
ocean to feed other fit exactly so if
you look at the publicly traded
companies that do that right they're
companies that especially have fishing
fleets they go capture the fish they
process it and keep these ingredients to
sell ingredients the publicly traded
ones seem to have around a seven percent
average profitability right our gross
margins should be 60% at scale yeah now
that's not all gonna that's not going to
translate to call the corporate
profitability
but there's a huge difference they're
huge and so sustainability that's all it
takes you to instead of take wildlife
yeah yeah and so that means that our
production cost is just much lower yeah
that's the simplest way to say now now
can you use just any co2 does it have to
be like a somewhat clean source of co2
yeah we like dirty co2 cuz that's cheap
or people might pay us to take it and in
our bacteria actually eat a lot of the
things or you could say eat or remediate
a lot of the things that the EPA is
actually concerned about in emissions
are we not then eating the co2 the dirty
co2 because then if the bacteria it's
the co2 fish eat the bacteria then we
eat the fish so digestion is all about
breaking things down yeah and when the
bacteria take in these compounds they're
chemoautotrophs they get food from
chemicals so they're actually they're
chemical reactions going in the bacteria
that are taking apart the molecules that
would be problematic for people so when
they take apart the problematic molecule
then that what-what occur so that it's
not there then at all well it's it's
like the same elements can either be
something very benign like a healthy
protein or it could be a poison right so
a good example this is actually our
bacteria can take apart cyanide so we
would remediates
cyanide if it was in a in a flu stock
that the one thing that we can't you
can't take apart right our elements so
we have to avoid elemental contaminants
like mercury like arsenic or Radio
isotopes which is also is that also why
you can't like take mercury out of this
whole fishing seafood dilemma is because
it's something that limits our ability
to take that element out yeah I mean the
mercury gets in through the water and up
through the food chain from like the
very smallest creatures playing to fight
Oakley and so once you get a tuna are
you gonna get the mercury out or do you
make like go sell buy like Elvis
even even then I don't think we have the
nanotechnology for that so the best
thing is prevent the mercury from going
in in the first place and for us that
means if the smokestack has a lot of
mercury coming out of it we don't use
that smokestack and there are billions
of tons a year of co2 from different
kinds of sources and so it's easy to
avoid a relatively easy to gravitate to
the ones that are producing the right
kind of dirty co2 yeah for us yeah and
it's so interesting about how the
bacteria breaks the molecule to the
point where we're not actually there's a
chemical process that goes on that makes
it so that we don't eat that and I'm
speaking generically but yes this is
what we try and do on the show we try
and get down to that I take care that
every possible
you know problematic molecule could be
broken down but we've looking at we've
looked at the main ones that are
actually present in flue gasses and
we're confident that we can find sources
in cement plants steel mills oil and gas
facilities pulp and paper mills and bio
ethanol manufacturing among other those
are just the top five just that's a
strange question I guess as you scale
over time the amount of fossil fuels
that we use decreases over time so where
do you get your dirty co2 from then well
so there are a lot of industrial
processes that are not related to fossil
fuels that just have to create co2 so oh
interesting like so cement for example
that just the the chemical process for
the formation of cement produces a ton
of co2 for every ton of cement
approximately right and so you know down
the street here if you go to Cupertino
there's Lehigh cement which is part of
the Heidelberg group which one of the
largest if not the largest cement group
in the world and that particular
facility puts off about 1.2 million tons
a year of co2 and we could make 600,000
tons a year of our nuovo meal from that
whoa and that's a lot the state of
California limits these guys to
releasing the amount of co2 that they
did in the late 70s or early 80s and so
if their co2 wasn't being emitted
that's right they could make more cement
cement which is what they're in the
business of doing so there's a lot of
value here not just in this incredible
protein but it also just make you know
reusing the co2 and preventing it from
going directly into the atmosphere now
are you positioned right next to the
cement factory or are you positioned at
a centralized location where the cement
factories from around the world ship
their co2 to you well so that there are
cement factories that are significantly
bigger than the one in Cupertino there
are ones that are four million tons a
year or more right and at four million
tons that creates 2 million tons a year
of product which would be valued at
around 3 billion dollars which means
it's it has the same value as the annual
production of soybeans from Nebraska
which is like 330 million bushels that's
a lot of protein and so it it we don't
we won't need multiple sources coming to
one point we can we can take the
production to the inputs and the inputs
are co2 cooled and hydrogen so that's
the other part is the hydrogen the
hydrogen okay okay
and then now just give us the kind of
the the you know the fish a meal that
you make the super fish fish meal that
you make that that then is fed to
aquaculture systems around the world
through what would be this right yeah
would so so there are are multi-billion
dollar companies all they do is they
make feed and some of them make feed for
pigs and chickens and fish some just
make feed for shrimp some just make feed
for salmon and so these feed milling
companies will be our customers feed
milling feed mills oh cool yeah then you
sell to them and they go and distribute
it to salmon or shrimp or whatever exact
because well they're in the business of
buying a wide variety of ingredients
mixing them in different recipes and
creating these feeds which are a lot
like they look a lot like and are a lot
like a dry cat or dog food and then
that's their product that they sell the
farms or they sell to distributors
okay great great is there something else
about novo nutrients that we should know
on the way oh yeah
everything I've just described is
natural and will be regulated as such
but half of our team are synthetic
biologists and they're thinking about
what kind of engineering can we do to
create even higher value better
performing products and so a lot of the
things that today are considered that
get put into feed like vitamins enzymes
carotenoids which are really good
antioxidants right omega-3s are things
that we can have our bacteria
manufacture internally and then they
won't have to be added to feed because
we'll be delivering these this
value-added protein meal that's enhanced
with all these valuable bio chemicals
and then our customers the feed moles
won't have to buy those things
separately they'll get a nice bundle and
and that opens up all kinds of
possibilities and the reason why we can
do that is because we have a generalized
bio manufacturing platform that we have
chosen to use first in animal nutrition
and aquaculture because it's that's just
such a great initial market but it
represents a fraction of what we can do
this and are you are you where do you
sit on like the long term push for with
companies like finless that are working
on growing the actual fish short the big
bioreactors we see that was potential
customers for us because we create
nutrients from non nutrients and
companies like finless and New Age meats
and Memphis meats take nutrients and
turn them into food so in a sense
they're actually very much like a fish
farmer so they were any other farm
directly from you we think we can
produce products for them yeah yeah
right because they want proteins and
fats that they're tuna cells can take up
and grow grow and replicate these tuna
cells are not interests are not capable
of taking the small molecules and
reproducing the way that our bacteria
can and so we we really want these new
food
needs to succeed because that's a market
where we can get in on the ground floor
and provide a higher quality protein to
them and and other things that they need
at a lower cost and and this is also
true for the plant-based meat companies
right so with your rip bowl or beyond
meat or impossible you're out there
buying a lot of specialized proteins
from made from peas or lentils but
really what you're interested in a high
quality protein that doesn't cost you
more than it has to
and so yeah we really want to be a
foundation of the food system whether
people are doing cellular agriculture
plant-based
meats or doing it sort of the
old-fashioned way by raising pigs or
chickens or mediterranean sea bass I
would have never stumbled upon that this
notion that you can have bacteria
consume microbes consuming co2 that then
can feed evolutions amazing man and and
we didn't have to build it right it was
out there for us we just had to put it
in the right framework yep in the right
friend yeah yeah and again it's it's
it's it's it's the design of the of the
selection of the specific amino acids
that make those proteins that then can
be fed to the our core intellectual
property is a framework for designing
consortium of microbes yeah couldn't
source you of not just bacteria but our
patent application also specifies
specific types of yeast microalgae yeah
other fungi yeah that can all work
together and we're just enabling the
growth not only of our workhorse
bacteria that can work that can live on
the co2 and hydrogen directly but dozens
of other species that have their own
special properties that can now
indirectly live on co2 and hydrogen
that's the magic the the
Oh Kasasa of microbes can use the co2 as
the fuel for them and do they then make
the specific proteins that you want to
feed the fish yeah we don't have like
precise protein by protein control right
yeah but you can change the corn source
you it's like gonna work a straw so you
can orchestra so you can know we want
this many violins we want this many
trumpets we want this many French horns
and that's the stuck it's the sound
right you can't get it exactly like
you're not going to get the sound waves
exactly what you want but you can get
very close and sort of you know close
enough for government work this has been
so interesting again like you said
evolution so fascinating you just got to
put the right parts of the piece to get
pieces together and then boom you can do
almost anything like that
this is nuts as humans we've now evolved
to the point where we can use other
evolution and guide it and so yeah
directed evolution hopefully with lots
of stewardship and love for planet Earth
and absolutely like taking co2 huh from
these cement plants and putting it into
fish peas is so so interesting do you
think thank you so much my pleasure
really on our show it's been super fun
thanks everyone for tuning in much
appreciated
[Music]